another weekend of anti-cop Anarchy in
Atlanta and what police call a
coordinated attack this violence
resulting in domestic terrorism charges
police pelted with fireworks bricks and
even Molotov cocktails as rioters
dressed in black launched an all-out
assault on what they call cop City
that's a proposed 90 million dollar
training facility for law enforcement it
has been repeatedly attacked by
anti-police and environmental agitators
in the past year some of them are even
living in the woods The Clash resulting
in violence and Flames protesters
setting construction equipment Ablaze at
least 35 people have been arrested 23 of
them charged with domestic terrorism and
get this authorities say many are from
out of town the police chief making it
clear that these attacks will not be
tolerated
moved toward the training center site
armed with fireworks rocks Molotov
cocktails another device and launched a
coordinated criminal attack against
officers actions such as this will not
be tolerated when you attack law
enforcement officers when you damage
equipment you are breaking the law
criminal activity will not be tolerated
in Atlanta nor tolerated in connection
with this project
but the Anarchy may not be over
Georgia's attorney general with this
warning on America's Newsroom great show
there are some individuals as I'm told
that went back into the forest last
night and uh there may be an operation
going on right now we will hold
everybody accountable that is engaged in
violent activity protesters use words
rioters use violence and again in
Georgia you can be charged with domestic
terrorism for engaging in this type of
behavior let's go to the legal side of
things or whatever else you want to
comment on on this story judge well
first of all I I saw the interview on
America's news it's really fantastic and
I love the fact that um that that
individual is like very clear this is
Georgia you know we're in a place where
we respect the law and you can't come
here especially what everyone but two
people are from Georgia they're not only
not from the state they're from out of
the country some of them from Canada
from France who are these people who
believe in Anarchy who want to destroy
this cop Training Center I mean when you
first of all look at all of them okay a
lot of them are young one of them
apparently is a lawyer in The Amazing
part of it is like you don't even know
what their beef is other than they hate
cops after George Floyd we decided we
were going to retrain cops this is a
training center this is exactly for that
purpose to retrain cops and in the end
what they're doing is they're destroying
the training center and and by the way
I'm tired of hearing about spontaneous
protests these are not spontaneous this
is so planned to have people from out of
the state out of the country and these
are people who distrust the institutions
uh they everybody there is a victim and
they believe in Anarchy and they want to
take down our country and they're
starting with this law enforcement and
and in the end what we've got to do is
make it real clear you don't go to
places like this and if you attack a law
enforcement officer it's usually up one
level in terms of felonies and I hope
they hold to it I hope they don't plea
bargain these cases I hope they take
them to the mat Jessica where's Stacy
Abrams today this is like a perfect
issue for her
it is a good issue for Highland well but
the problem would be what side are you
going to be on on this right so after
Biden caught all that Flack last week
for quote changing his mind and even
though he never said he was going to
veto the bill but basically coming down
on the side of
normalcy and order in terms of the DC
crime Bill same side as the mayor of DC
as well it's not the best environment
for people to come out and be anti-law
enforcement necessarily that kind of
seems like a phase that we've passed
which I think is a good thing I think
comments from people like the New York
city mayor talking about what was the
line Public Safety is a prerequisite for
Prosperity that's something that Mayors
Big City Mayors all over the country are
thinking about Keisha Lance bottoms who
was the mayor of Atlanta certainly was
as well I totally agree with the judge
the fact that it's 23 of 25 or 21 of 23
who are from elsewhere just seems
completely absurd and the police chief
was very clear if this had been peaceful
protest it would have gone on this is
obviously not peaceful and the
juxtaposition when we're hearing about
this story and you have Biden in Selma
for the anniversary of Bloody Sunday and
you think about what real civil rights
challenges were in this country and the
people traveled for that you want to
travel for that that makes sense to me
if you want to travel to protest the BM
Vietnam War you travel for that but
you're traveling what because a few
people got thrown out of a forest yep
you mentioned Eric Adams this is the
mayor of New York City we have one call
for we shall listen to
I think it's the one to sign for the
Country Public Safety is a prerequisite
to Prosperity same in Chicago like New
York and many of our big cities Across
America we are focused on Public Safety
because people want to be saved they
don't feel safe and they're actually
safe then you're going to lose control
of your city and the other thing that's
gone I imagine to the people of Georgia
or even like right there in Atlanta is
that they're those taxpayers that are
paying for the police facility and now
people from out of town and even out of
the country are coming and firebombing
it well the left loves antifa they've
romanticized antifa for years now
because at heart every left Winger is a
revolutionary they always admired their
parents or maybe the parents themselves
when they were out protesting Nam or
making their dumb placards that's what
they dream of doing to be able to be
this free-spirited and to not care about
the consequences and to do things that
in their hearts they know they believe
because the far left does hate the
police and so they're they're honored by
these people but it's hard hard for them
to talk about because it's so awkward so
they don't talk about it the binder came
out today and said the president had
never heard of this
no statements from either Democrat
senator in Georgia right about this it's
like it doesn't exist because it hurts
the narrative remember these people were
against Maga so it's like the enemy of
Miami is my friends with benefits
because this is really more romantic
than we realize I mean these people
it's like a girl that's crazy that might
steal your car and burn your house down
but makes your toes curl this is the
type of relationship the left has with
these people and even the New York Times
came out today it was spinning that this
was about an environmental protest like
they were going to save the trees I
didn't know antifa was for the
environment they weren't in East
Palestine they're not at the Jersey
Shore when the whales wash up so that
was news to me this is always about
these hardcore people that are against
the police and like the judge said this
is a facility where they train to
negotiate hostage situations where they
train in getaway cars where they do mass
shooting drills so they had to kill some
trees to do this okay
um do you want a few trees did or do you
want everybody in Atlanta dead from a
mass shooter trees are in Georgia
seriously and the feds and the Feds all
of a sudden are like okay well this is a
Loosely organized group
well how loose is it if it's from France
and Canada every state in the Union then
they come in and do this and the mug
shots it was like the Faces of Meth do
you ever see where they do the meth
poster yeah I'm just going to bring that
up because apparently one of the things
these antifa people hate Greg is when
their pictures are shown everywhere so
let's put them up so that everybody can
see them yeah well I gotta say uh
generally it would be this would be the
opportunity for for me to mock their
looks oh but you know what
true there are some very homely people
in here uh but there's a few just a few
handsome guys in here I will say that
about the women look miserable uh so I'm
going to go back I'm I I don't want to
make this a bigger story than it is I
think that we're looking at a fringe
group that has been poisoned poisoned by
the media their brains have been
poisoned maybe in 10 years or 15 years 5
10 of this group may come out of it and
look back in shame or you might just
have another Weather Underground guy who
thinks it was really great but you look
at this it but
wonder when you think about the fact
that we are now we they and the police
are clashing over a training facility
how absurd this has become this kind of
battle and that the fact that like
listening to Jessica if it weren't
Jessica if it was Harold it was Ronaldo
they would all be we're all in agreement
so we've talked about this two weeks ago
a week ago why
why if everybody's in agreement why is
this still happening when this is out
and you can say that about seven or
eight different kind of news stories why
is this still happening why is there a
Canadian teacher with giant boobs
allowed to teach like why are these
stories still going on and I really
think it's to keep us busy that's what I
think I think like in a weird way you
know if we're at each other's throats we
won't be at theirs which means that
people that are in charge so we're so
the fact that this stuff can keep
getting worse is only because we're
staying out of trouble in other ways
right this is like a it's like a weird
Side Show going on uh that keeps the
power in in power think about this like
if if we didn't have this phone and
we're walking down like you're walking
down the Lower East Side with this phone
this is the most technological Advanced
product in the history of the world
probably and you're stepping over half
dead zombies as you're holding this so
there's this incredible competence here
but then everything around you on that
street is total incompetence you've got
homelessness drug addiction and crime so
you have this weird clash and it's like
the reason why we have to be distracted
is so we don't stop and say this means
you got to go like there's so much
incompetence in this world and we're too
distracted this is like this is just a
game this is like you know uh uh you
know it's like ooh antifa here and uh
proud boys there like that's basically
Keeps Us busy well it's easy to knock
this off because you just arrest these
people yeah just based on looks or
traffic but we don't arrest them right
but then the question is is there
cashless bail in Georgia I don't know
what the standard is and George I
suspect it's chaos as well but none of
them have roots in the community which
used to be the test for keeping someone
in jail so we'll see it's interesting
because then you like you're more likely
to stick around yeah if you have roots
in the community you have a job you have
a family you have a house you're more
likely to stick around and that's why
you go to other places because you you
don't it doesn't you don't mind burning
down do you want to go to France with me
and protest and Riot yeah
we're on TV well I'm gonna have a blast
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now